when i got invited it sounded really
small
well let's talk about bryce hall and
this way house they faced a lot of
backlash for that party girl so i have
to ask you because you were there
nobody told me how many people were
gonna be there and i went when it was
super early and i still have my mask
there so i left way before it got like
crazy
yeah i got there really early if you
check my snapchat story the lights were
on
when i got there so people don't know
the full story like i was there for like
20 minutes
before it like got crazy well like
considering the fact that it's your
circle like
do you think how do you feel about him
throwing the party do you think he was
wrong for doing
doing that looking back knowing i don't
i feel like maybe he didn't know how big
it was gonna be like when i got invited
it sounded really small like it's bryce
hall's birthday like come through
we're just gonna like have a couple of
drinks so like to me that sounds like
a small kickback so i feel like maybe he
didn't know or maybe
all it takes is one person to invite
another person to invite another person
an address
addresses are constantly getting leaked
and i feel like that it could have been
a situation like that but also those
boys party hard so
i don't really know we might need more
for tonight
hey happy birthday to me what's your
response to people who who keep saying i
see it in your comments all the time
why are you out why are you doing this
what do you have to say well first of
all
like it's crazy to get comments like
that when like i
literally took quarantine so freaking
says so many friends of mine were
literally going to arizona traveling
like not wearing a mask
i am such a social person so just being
cooped up in my house
is not ideal you know i really want to
venture out
but i can't i'm like the mask dealer
like
i carry mass like i carry tampons i'm
not kidding like i have like
packs of packs of masks in my backpack
in my room
in my car so whenever i go out i'm
always wearing a mask i'm always making
sure
that you know i am protecting myself and
protecting others around me
one two three four
all these clothes and i just want more
take top
you know there's a lot of bugs going
around that it might
get shut down i don't know if that's
actually going to happen
but what's been the vibe in the house
what type of conversations have you all
had
surrounding that um the clubhouse group
chat was like freaking out when it was
announced on twitter but i was like
honestly
i doubt it's gonna happen um i'm i work
closely with tick-tock and they like
calmed me down and
like everything's fine i think they're
just changing um
like management or something uh but
i think it's gonna be fine honestly i
don't see it going anywhere
anytime soon i truly don't